listas no tenía otra opción que dar un
paso al costado hemos visto en las ya
acostumbradas escenas Raúl de dramatismo
y de inestabilidad en la política
británica desde hace varios meses que
listras cada vez más era el asunto
fundamental el país está tratando de
avanzar de salir después de esta crisis
económica en la que se encuentra pero
los expertos y los diputados
conservadores que pusieron a distrasas
Hace seis semanas en el cargo afirmaban
que ella era la piedra en el zapato para
avanzar de hecho su ministro de finanzas
que era su Aliado político fue
sacrificado por ella misma hace menos de
una semana para poder sobrevivir pero no
fue suficiente que ha pasado en las
últimas 24 horas pues debo decirles que
de todo lo primero es que la ministra
del interior suele haberme Man dio un
paso al costado dijo que se iba por
haber es un código de confidencialidad
al enviar un email un correo electrónico
a un diputado conservador con
información confidencial pero leyendo La
carta de su renuncia dejaba claro que
esa era la razón menos importante para
dar un paso al costado y que en realidad
tenía serias diferencias con el gobierno
de listras y especialmente por cometer
errores errores gravísimos que hemos
visto a lo largo de estas seis semanas
tuvieron un impacto en los mercados y en
el precio de la libra esterlina se
preguntaban además las personas en la
calle si cada vez estaban teniendo menos
recursos con esta situación económica
que estamos viviendo Así que listas no
tenía otra salida se sabía que la
decisión de los conservadores era que
ella tenía que irse pero lo que quedaba
por sortear es el como y el cuándo y esa
Raúl son a una de las preguntas cuando
cuando será entiendo que no ha dado una
fecha ha dicho que va a empezar a a
conocerse Cuál será el proceso para
elegir al nuevo líder pero no sabemos
finalmente cuándo será cuando listas
finalmente deje down Street y menos Qué
tipo de proceso elegirá los
conservadores para sucederla se sabía en
estas últimas 24 horas que el umbral de
las 54 cartas que requiere el partido
conservador para poder sacar un Primer
Ministro con una moción de confianza ya
se había alcanzado Y hoy por eso se da
esta reunión del disfraz con graham
Brady que es el jefe del poderoso comité
1922 es tan poderoso porque puede sacar
o mantener un Primer Ministro la primera
ministra se reunió con él esta mañana
este mediodía para intentar tener la
temperatura de los diputados
conservadores y lo cierto Es que listas
ha tomado la decisión entonces de irse
tras solo seis semanas en el cargo lista
seguramente será conocida como listas la
primera mini la más breve Luisa y
también esta reunión o Por así decirlo
fue para que ella saliera con la cabeza
en alto y que no la votara no que no
pues la apartaran de su cargo sino ella
pues dar un paso al costado tras
reunirse con el presidente de
1922 para decirle pues ya no tienes
opciones si no lo haces igual te vamos a
sacar entonces me imagino que ella pues
se tomó esta decisión esto abre
evidentemente un sin número de preguntas
Luisa y la primera que se me viene a la
mente Es realmente el partido
conservador estaría en su mejor momento
habría una crisis dentro del partido
conservador porque también lo vimos no
hace nada tuvimos estas elecciones
listos fue elegida como la primera
ministra no eligieron a rishizuna quien
competía con ella para hacer el sucesor
de Boris Johnson en ese entonces qué
pasa realmente dentro del partido
conservador porque la votaron a ella
sabiendo que no iba a poder liberar el
país que no iba a poder digamos asumir
las riendas económicas del país que es
lo que ahora más preocupa a todos en los
a todos los británicos las personas que
viven dentro de Reino Unido entonces que
realmente está pasando dentro de ese
partido Luisa no sé que nos pueda
adelantar Qué dice la prensa y que se
conoce en este momento si hay realmente
Una crisis dentro del partido
conservador de los Stories
sí sin duda la crisis se remonta hace
varios años podríamos incluso decirlo
que desde
2015 cuando ese entonces David Cameron
el Primer Ministro tuvo que fijar esa
fecha del referendo para el brexit
porque estaba generando serias disputas
dentro del partido conservador Y a
partir de ese momento ojo hemos tenido
cuatro primeros ministros conservadores
llevan 12 años en el poder y lo cierto
es que los cambios que el país necesitan
las tareas urgentes por ser resueltas no
se han hecho porque el país ha tenido
que enfocarse en todo este drama
político como lo mencionabas que hemos
tenido que presenciar en estos últimos
años es increíble lo que está sucediendo
en este país y lo hemos hablado Raúl
largamente en nuestras emisiones de lo
increíble que está sucediendo los
surrealista que estamos presenciando en
el Reino Unido estamos hablando de una
de las democracias bacterias del país de
hecho de economics ese
prestigiosísimos semanario ha Comparado
la política británica con la Italiana
Así que esa es la situación si el
partido conservador en este momento está
viviendo una crisis profunda los Stories
han reconocido públicamente que se
equivocaron listas ofreció un plan
económico para solventar la situación
económica que está viviendo todo el país
pero no era el adecuado y ella en sus
razones de renuncia ha dicho que ese
plan inicial que ella diseñó pues ya no
se está acorde con las situaciones que
estamos viviendo Pero sobre todo porque
el ministro de finanzas con quien ella
diseñó este plan de salvación del país
pues no funcionó fue destrozado por el
nuevo ministro de finanzas y entonces
salitras no le quedaba más posibilidad
que dar un paso al costado porque no
tiene credibilidad